[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GORDON CHAMBERS:
So now we're going
to do some songs from the
most current album, "Sincere."
I shot this video of this
song in my house in Brooklyn.
Is Brooklyn in the house?
[CHEERING]
GORDON CHAMBERS: I shot
it right in my own house.
And it featured in it an
amazing acting performance
by a friend of ours who's an
amazing singer named Sy Smith.
So if you check out the
video for this song,
you'll see her acting
her behind off.
And you'll also see a woman
who surprised me and came out
tonight.
She's also in the video.
Miss Ebony Jo-Ann
is in the house.
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Acting her
behind off in the video.
You gotta love soul artists,
because we work together,
and we're there for each
other when we need each other,
aren't we, Ebony?
And I think she's
working on her album.
So anyway, this song is a song
that, actually, Troy Taylor
wanted Trey Songz to record.
[SINGING] And Trey said,
no, no, no, no, no.
And I said yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's called "I Can't Love
You (If You Don't Love You)."
Can I get a witness?
[MUSIC - GORDON CHAMBERS,
"I CAN'T LOVE YOU (IF YOU
DON'T LOVE YOU)"]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Sing
along if you know it.
[MUSIC - GORDON CHAMBERS,
"I CAN'T LOVE YOU (IF YOU
DON'T LOVE YOU)"]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Sing, y'all.
[MUSIC - GORDON CHAMBERS,
"I CAN'T LOVE YOU (IF YOU
DON'T LOVE YOU)"]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Ricky
Ramos on guitar, y'all.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - GORDON CHAMBERS,
"I CAN'T LOVE YOU (IF YOU
DON'T LOVE YOU)"]
GORDON CHAMBERS:
[SINGING] Give it up!
Give it up!
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - GORDON CHAMBERS,
"I CAN'T LOVE YOU (IF YOU
DON'T LOVE YOU)"]